Christian I wanted to start with you
because of course I was reading that you
saw a whole bunch of tapes for the role
of Poe but when you saw Harry's you're
like that is our guy so what was it
about Harry's take that signaled to you
he was your right actor for that role
versus anyone else he just he he nailed
something and he was getting something I
could see he was getting something out
of this performance in an audition which
is the worst time to actually do
anything interesting in acting I've
always been abysmal at auditions I have
no idea how I ever got cast in anything
um but I watched it he was hypnotizing
he just made me only see him as po
afterwards and score greed yeah he's
bloody good to add to that a little when
when you're also involved in the
audition process of a film that you're
working on what can you be looking for
in a potential co-star that signals to
you that person won't just nail their
role but they'll also be a good
collaborator for for me to play with in
terms of how you like to work with your
scene partner well that's always a risk
you know you never know that until you
actually get it on the set and on its
feet you know
um but that you know that's the risk
with every uh film that you do you know
and by the way I'm not casting Scott is
generous enough to share these with me
Scotty's casting he knows that your
collaborations pay off though the more
you two work together
enjoy working together absolutely yes
yeah I I I you know I want his advice on
my acting and he is generous enough to
uh pretend to listen to my thoughts oh
please I don't believe that for a second
Harry I'll throw a scene partner
question your way for Christian now is
there any particular scene in this movie
that you found especially challenging
but because Christian gave you what you
needed as a scene partner you were able
to reach something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
without him yeah I think um for me first
days are always quite tough because you
just want to get off you know to a to a
not a good start but a a solid start
from where you can move forward and so
um I would always remember that first
day being uh in that very darkened um
room in Landorus Cottage and it was just
a very gentle uh very um they gave me
the space in order to to find out your
first that was my first and you had a
lot I didn't notice
yeah nice one man you did a great job I
just had time and and Christian's so
generous in terms of
um giving you the space to really play
and find things and and just as always
present so um yeah that would that would
come to mind in terms of
yeah first days can be tricky and when I
was off camera I always drew the face on
the tennis ball I left that there so I
could go for lunch exactly yeah yeah but
we don't talk about that yet again
another thing I don't believe for a
second
um given how much uh Poe changes over
the course the film I guess I don't
really know how much this would apply to
a film where I'm assuming you do not get
to shoot in sequence very often but is
there any particular scene of his that
like really put who he was as a person
at that time into perspective for you
where no matter what decisions he made
along the way you could always refer
back to that moment know his decisions
were being made in some sort of Truth
yeah good question I think maybe not a
moment in a scene but a thing that I
kept coming back to was the idea that
Lando offers him something that he needs
this this anchor this sense of place
this sense of belonging and I also knew
that I had to give Lando enough reasons
to fall in love with Poe yes you meet
him he could be this very foolish very
strange creature but I had to give him
enough reasons to sort of
to want to invest in this person and and
so those were things that I I knew had
to happen and and then
um from there sort of let things reveal
themselves to me as opposed to
necessarily reaching for them it's a
beautiful uh piece to that reveal I love
it so much Christian I want to ask you a
broader career question because you kind
of did this earlier in this interview
and I feel like every single time I've
spoken to you you're so incredibly
humble about your wildly incredible
filmography is there any particular
scene you've ever shot that now makes
even you say like like damn that was
tough I crushed it and I'm so proud of
it uh no I don't think that
um I do think
how incredibly lucky I've been to be in
some of the situations work with some of
the people and you know just looking
there was a gentleman interviewing us
earlier on and he had an Empire of the
Sun DVD next to him and just thinking
about oh my God the things that I
experienced on that were phenomenal
which as you were referring to as a
child you just get on with stuff you
don't look at it in comparison to other
things at all but just how fortunate I
was and I'm thinking in particular these
brilliant pilots who were actually
flying right at my head on top of a
building and then dipping the wing so we
get even closer and just loving it and I
would go up in the planes with them
afterwards but being there having that
kind of an experience having just the
absolute expertise of people who have
built this entire crazy set which is
unheard of I don't think I sell like
that would be built anymore and then
being 13 doing that and then I turned
around nobody left on the rooftop they'd
all run because they thought they the
plane was gonna crash and I was the only
one left but they left the camera
running and we got the scene but these
incredible moments that you get to have
that I never would have expected uh
having in my life but anyway that was
the one that just jumped into my head as
you started asking that question with
that in mind and with everything else
you've experienced is there anything in
particular in pale blue eye that even
with all those experiences made you go
on set like damn I never realized that
you know either I would be capable or us
as a team would be capable of making
that happen one day yeah I never
realized that you could um uh keep warm
by just rubbing lard all over your body
and I never realized that Harry would
copy me in doing that who posed that
idea
I mean I'm cold 24 7 so now there's
going to be some awkward moments yeah
and like you guys wouldn't judge me but
everybody else on the planet will